[Music]
antichess
okay so i know this is theory
i don't know this is the best move by
the way andy chester believe white wins
um so i know that an anti-chess moving
pawns two squares early on in the game
was not a very very good idea so i'm
supposed to yes i thing is just loses
for black guessing this is just lost
black is lost guys yeah
yeah gg go next
oh i'm so toxic all right let's go
i'm gonna show you guys my imperfect
technique
my perfect winning technique
in anti-chess
ah so at this point i can pretty much do
whatever i believe
this this
this
this
this
this this
this
this
and that
if you guys want to challenge me for
why why don't keep getting white i mean
i know that that an anti-chess where i
suppose supposedly winning in and then
you know yeah
um
but i don't i don't know how i'm winning
yeah i know b5 is yeah this is a theory
um yep take stakes
yeah
but this is this is this is this is the
extent of my theoretical knowledge in
antichess this is this is this is it i
don't know anything else
now i'm on all on my own
and this kinds of spots where you're all
on your own actually show how good of a
player you are
why is the game why is the king so far
up
wait a minute wait am i winning here
actually i might be winning here i think
i think i won
yeah i think this is it i think it's
over
gg
here
ladies and gentlemen
there's no stalemate in this game
ladies and gentlemen there is no
stalemate in this game
get him out of here
and this is why this is why i like andy
chess a lot of calculation you can
literally calculate to the end how did
you lose
um how do you lose well i would say
i can i can explain actually so i think
this is how you lost in this move
uh if you didn't make this move you
wouldn't have lost
if you just play like something neutral
like let's say
knight e7
yeah we can you can play again let's go
king c6 is worth the loss okay so g3 all
right
it should be fine
i'll show you how
i mean
it's it's clear
i think i i think i'm did i lose no not
yet
i think i'm fine for now
or am i
takes
yeah i think i'm okay
yeah i'm fine i think
yeah this is okay see i'm not i as long
as as long as i can make my opponent
take stuff i think i'm okay
uh yeah well done
[Laughter]
well i think i think i know what
happened
no nope nope i'm going to punish you for
this yeah you're getting punished
[Laughter]
nope i'm not let me let me take a couple
of seconds to think about this okay
uh i know what's just happened my
opponent expected me to take with the
bishop and obviously yeah
well you were winning with rook b2 as
the roxy one we all know that but
wait i'm sorry
no take backs aloud you do deserve to
win this game up come like no joke
but sometimes
you don't get you don't get what you
deserve
um okay well this is still actually very
interesting i don't see
i don't see how i can give up my pieces
immediately
let's sit here
yeah i can't okay so i can't give up all
the pieces right away
and that's fine
i'm gonna do this
i'm going to do this i'm going to take
back with the pawn obviously
sometimes you don't catch it
that's a song by the rolling stone still
really i had no idea uh let's play a
funny-looking move quinn to a8
um
i need to be very careful where i place
my king here so b5 have queen c6 if a5
a5 is fine
so i'm gonna go
let's go here it doesn't matter where i
go because b5 has to happen and queen c6
has to happen so these two moves
pretty much have to happen
and now
this is this is the hard part this is
the part where
this is the hard part ah here
the knight
yeah i think they should do it here here
knight right has to become a knight i
believe
or a bishop i think bishop is fine too
but if it becomes a bishop then i have a
couple of very nice
here here here here here
i don't know this looks like a draw
night yes okay so the night was exactly
what i thought was going to happen but
now
here
here
no
no no no no no no no no oh my god
wait no it's fine why am i why am i so
upset i'm okay i won
here why am i so upset here
here
got him
i'm sorry i'm so sorry
i think if you take back with the bishop
and if you take on the it was a making
bishop i think it's it's a draw why did
you pre-move yeah yeah you you yeah that
was that was perfect
you play the perfect games there and
unfortunately see you
you butchered it and it's just one
mistake is all it takes yep